oh thank you see everybody's excited
we're excited Jennifer Aniston showing
off her gray hair yeah I thought it was
quite shocking and and it's gorgeous Jen
rocked her silver roots in this
Instagram video and fans Can't Get
Enough oh thank you see I'm just excited
we're excited I think it'll spark a lot
of conversation and it has comments
blooded the friend star's post with
praises for Jen embracing her natural
look good for me it's the first time the
actress has given the world a peek at
her grades fans are used to seeing Jen
in her signature brown blonde look and
on Tuesday Jen took it to the next level
Sterling locks front and center in a
workout vid
what would you tell your younger self
about your own power about anything
you'd wish you'd known
how important your voice is
and your confidence yes Jen is embracing
those grades I'm very peaceful I feel
very peaceful
I literally think that every day like
wake up and feel very lucky
you feel very fortunate yeah and she's
not the only celeb showing off her
natural dresses I'm so proud Salma Hayek
shared this up close look at her roots
with the caption me waking up and
Counting how many white hairs and
wrinkles have crashed the party this
morning it's a reminder
that we cannot stop living life we love
to see these amazing women showing off
their natural locks as you grow older
um you have to
just believe in love and put love into
everything around you oh thank you see
everybody's excited we're excited